what's up tio it's alex calling again
from la
alex calling from la onward uh i just
thought you uh
might want to hear a quick story about
this past weekend
and did he call before nick he said
again i think we haven't used his
voicemail
okay first time okay let's hear more um
it started off with me going to work
and getting a weird feeling with my boss
and she called me outside and she fired
so i got fired for my job and on my way
damn she sounds kind of sexy more
way home from getting fired um
i was hit by two cars a
threesome automobile accident
and uh messed up my wrist kind of bad so
my car got totaled
and during the accident my phone hit the
windshield from my passenger seat
and broke into a million pieces it
didn't break into a million pieces dude
i mean i could see it breaking but it
definitely didn't that's
i'm not calling you out bro but that's a
wild cliche to use in that moment
careful with it hyperbole yeah dude it
broke maybe it
shattered and kind of broke some but
anyway you could just set my anyway what
the [ __ ] am i talking about now how many
cars actually hit them you know
yeah that's true yeah you hurt your
wrist bro
first of all who even has a wrist dude
most people just don't even [ __ ]
think about their wrist
dude your wrist your hand will be fine
bro there's skin connecting
it you gotta do you gotta toughen
up you're working for a lady
first of all that's awesome man good for
you times are different
and it's okay and i've worked for many
women over the years and i know a lot of
men out there are married or as they
like to call it
working for a woman so i so we can all
relate to that
but dude then you get into a three-car
collision and all that happens
you're at your [ __ ] wrist bro man up
dude [ __ ] die
or don't get hurt at all none of this
middle ground
dude it's like [ __ ] kids are getting
soft man that's america
get on some opioids dude why don't you
do that he had some he had some
one more thing happen to him though and
um
i lost my job my car and my phone in
like an
hour and that that
so you know i didn't let it get me down
but kind of sucked a little bit
so the next morning i have to walk a
couple miles to school
it's a school well how what is going on
here
how would how how old are you every age
let's hear more well i get stuff figured
out and um
i go to citrus college in azusa and uh
there was a school shooting scare so we
got a lockdown for
10 hours and that was my past weekend
i've had i've had better weekends for
sure but i'm not gonna let it get me
down you know
damn bro do we listen more nick you
think
no he's not gonna let him get it down
wow
dude i think
you might want to go to church or
something dude or wrap yourself in
bubble wrap dawg this might be your time
and you're out there cheating death so i
don't know how you handle that you know
dude you can't be cheating death brother
you got to tighten up
so i don't know what to do i would get
with the church or get with you you know
some latinos that are older
you know from some of the old city and
see if they could do some [ __ ]
put some hex on you or something you
know what i'm saying do that voodoo baby
you know put a couple of your if you
think if you pull a couple of your
sisters
chin hairs out and put them in your
buttocks or whatever they got that old
voodoo
make you stay safe but be do be well man
it might be my last damn time we ever
hear from that guy
so be well steve is that his name alex
yep
see he's even changing his name who
[ __ ] knows bruh
who even knows man but be safe alex and
good luck out there at least you're
walking to school and getting it done
you know at least you're getting it done
and uh and good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one